في محاوله لمواهمه التوقعات بين اداره
بايد وحكومه نتنياهو اليمنيه بمركباتها
المتطرفه غير المقبوله على الامريكيين حول
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي في اول
لقاءات رسميه مع اركانها التشديد على
ضروره استمرار التنسيق حول مواجهه ايران
وتجنب المفاجاهات ولا جيم سياسه الاستيطان
ومنع انفجار الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
فيما اوضح نتنياهو ان اولويته تبقى منع
ايران نوويه ورفض العوده لاتفاق معها
من خلال العمل المشترك مع ان يمكننا
مواجهه التحديات واستغلال الفرص ما يقوي
التحالف بيننا والجهد المشترك لوقف برنامج
ايران النووي
انقل تحياتي الرئيس ايضا الملتزم بعمق
بامي اسرائيل وامريكا ملتزمه باسرائيل
التزام فيه مبادئ مشتركه ونعمل بشكل مشترك
لمواجهه التحديات والفرس
سوليبان
الدفاع والخارجيه الاسرائيليين والرئيس
الاسرائيلي كما زعيم المعارضه ايضا وليس
من باب المصادفه ان يطلب الامريكيون من
اسرائيل تجميد خطه استراليا في القدس
الشرقيه المحتله بالتزامن مع زياره
سوليفان وان تشمل الزياره شنقا فلسطينيه
في محاوله للربط ما بين حاجه اسرائيل في
الملف الايراني ورغبه واشنطن في عدم تدمير
حل الدولتين على الارض تمام تماما
عليها ان تعمل على وقف كافه الاجراءات
احاديث الجانب من الجانب الاسرائيلي وهمم
من اجل فعلا ان همم نتمكن من
ايجاد نوع من الهدوء والاستقرار في الارض
الفلسطينيه المحتله في رام الله التقى
سلبان الرئيس الفلسطيني ومدير المخابرات
وسمع تحذيرا فلسطينيه من انفجار الوضع
الميداني وانهاء الحل السياسي ومطالبه
بالوفاء بتعهد الاداره الامريكيه باعاده
فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه
المحتله زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه